So, the amount of household debt and even
more recently of student debt in the U.S.
is something that is really troublesome and
it reflects the very large rise in tuition
in the U.S. a very large inequality in access
to education.
And I think if we really want to promote more
equal opportunity and redistribute chances
in access to education we should do something
about student debt.
And it's not possible to have such a large
group of the population entering the labor
force with such a big debt behind them.
This exemplifies a particular problem with
inequality in the United States, which is
very high inequality and access to higher
education.
So in other countries in the developed world
you don't have such massive student debt because
you have more public support to higher education.
And I think the plan that was proposed earlier
this year in 2015 by President Obama to increase
public funding to public universities and
community college is exactly justified.
This is really the key for higher growth in
the future and also for a more equitable growth.
There's one statistic, which I give in my
book, which is a bit frightening, which is
that if you look at the average income of
the parents of Harvard University graduate
students right now what you get is the equivalent
of the average income of the top two percent
of the U.S. distribution of family income.
So this doesn't mean that there's nobody from
below the top two percent that gets into Harvard,
but this means something very precise, which
is that people from below the top two that
make it to Harvard are sufficiently few.
And the people who come from the top two come
from sufficiently high within the top two,
that the overall average is as if all students
had been picked from within the top two percent
of the distribution of U.S. family income.
So this is an example which shows that you
have the official discourse about meritocracy,
equal opportunity and mobility, and then you
have the reality.
And the gap between the two can be quite troublesome.
So this is like you have a problem like this
and there's a lot of hypocrisy about meritocracy
in every country, not only in the U.S., but
there is evidence suggesting that this has
become particularly extreme in the United
States.
And of course, student debt at to the other
extreme of the distribution is the other side
of the coin.
So this is a situation that is very troublesome
and should rank very highly in the policy
agenda in the future in the U.S.